in this video we'll talk about necrosis
which is one type of cellulite and this
is a high yield topic for USMLE step one
watch the video till the end and don't
forget to subscribe necrosis is one type
of cell death which is associated with
any kind of pathology it is resulting
due to injury or infection let us talk
about some Hallmarks of necrosis one of
the prominent Hallmark is the plasma
membrane damage second thing necrosis
influences inflammatory responses which
are peculiar to necrosis and not found
in apoptosis so immune cells would come
into the picture and can evoke
inflammation
cell undergoes enzymatic degradation and
protein denaturation
also intracellular components might leak
such as lysosome there could be
dysfunctional of Mito dysfunction of
mitochondria and many other cellular
organelles these are prominent features
of necrosis
so lysosomalysis and mitochondrial
swelling and dysfunction are pretty
prominent a Hallmarks of necrosis
so in necrosis mitochondria swells up
and get localized into the perinuclear
region very adjacent to the nucleus
and there is also a calcium overload
which results in many detrimental
consequences plasma membrane ruptures
and it leads to leak out of cytoplasmic
fluid into the vicinity which is pretty
peculiar to necrosis and not found in
apoptosis lysosomal rupture leads to
release of several lysosomal enzymes
which degrades other proteins and many
affects other organelles inside the
cytoplasm excessive Ross production is a
feature of necrosis and since the
mitochondria is dysfunctional swelled up
ATP depletion is pretty common
when ATP levels goes down many enzymes
which require ATP cannot function
properly
as a whole the overall activity of the
cell and overall activity of many
enzymes are compromised in necrosis
another prominent feature is decoupling
of electron transport chain and the ATP
production which is very often seen in
necrosis
when it comes to mitochondria
cyclophylline deactivation is a
prominent feature and it leads to
dissipation of the proton gradient and
alteration in the membrane potential of
mitochondria so overall it makes the
mitochondria dysfunctional in addition
to that it leads to kalpin activation
and cathips in the activation which can
have other consequences in terms of
cellular physiology so overall we
understand that mitochondrial
dysfunction is a very prominent feature
in necrosis let's talk about the types
of necrosis
we have coagulative necrosis which is
often ischemia associated
we have a liquid effective
necrosis which can be found and most
likely they are associated with abscess
or bacterial or fungal infections
and then caseus necrosis which are very
often associated with fungal infection
and they have very prominent cheese-like
feature which we would describe in a
moment
there is fibrinoid and gangrinous
necrosis as well
starting with coagulative necrosis
when blood flows in the cell stops or
slows down it leads to a situation known
as ischemia it occurs anywhere in the
body but not in the brain the cells and
the tissue maintains their structure
after death but eventually get cleared
up by the immune cells the causes of
coagulative necrosis includes
atherosclerosis blood clot hernia
infections or some kind of like trauma
or injury
this is an example and a cross section
of heart where you can see uh ischemic
injury happened and which lead to a
coagulative necrosis that a dark red
patch
now liquefective necrosis is one type of
necrosis where the tissue transforms
into a liquid filled viscous Mass
and this is common for bacterial abscess
and sometimes CNS infracts often it is
associated with fungal infections as
well one of the major cell type or
immune cell type which is associated
with this kind of phenotype is
neutrophils
then we come to KCs necrosis in this
case we see a prominent cheese-like
appearance that can be found in this
image
so this necrosis is caused due to many
bacterial infection like TB also it
could be due to systemic fungal
infections like histoplasma or nucardia
infection
then there is gangrenous necrosis and
the digital extremities GI tract are the
most affected portions where blood flow
stops and it leads to necrosis of that
region
so clostridial myonecrosis is pretty
prominent feature of clostridium
infection
then fibrinoid necrosis happens due to
the death of cells in the small blood
vessels
and it can lead to bleeding and internal
hemorrhage
throughout the body and many conditions
can cause fiber fibrinoid necrosis
including too much hypertension when the
blood pressure increases so much it
might lead to death of the capillary
cells
also there could be autoimmune disease
which deposits uh immune complexes in
blood vessels and thereby harming the
blood vessels so these are the reason
for which fibrinoid necrosis can be
found so I hope this was useful and
informative if you like this video give
it a quick thumbs up don't forget to
like share and subscribe follow us on
Instagram and Facebook for more detail
notes you can support our Channel using
super thanks see you in next video